[music playing]
If we assume that the vision
of a floating city in the sky
that was seen in Foshan by
thousands of people was just
some kind of optical illusion,
I find it highly coincidental
that the same vision is seeing
hundreds of miles away a few
days later in another city
called Xiong'an, also witnessed
by thousands of people.
NARRATOR: Could thousands
of people across China
have really witnessed
some type of alien base
or mothership
floating in the sky?
And if so, might it be
evidence of extraterrestrials
making their presence known?
Ancient astronaut
theorists suggest
there have been many more cases
of alien entities appearing
in the skies above China--
cases that the government
could not ignore.
Zhejiang province,
China, July 7, 2010.
Just after 8:40 PM, the Hangzhou
Xiaoshan International Airport,
which serves over
70,000 passengers a day,
is suddenly shut down.
All outbound flights
are grounded,
and inbound flights are
diverted to nearby airports.
The cause of the shutdown was
an unidentified flying object
seen streaking
across the night sky
by a flight crew
preparing for descent.
Xiaoshan Airport is one
of the largest in China,
and that's very important.
It's a very busy airport.
What happened on July
7 is that a pilot
from an incoming
passenger airplane
noticed something very
unusual coming towards him.
He notified the ground crew,
and the airport was shut down,
because a comet-like
object was basically
speeding towards the airport.
There was a trail behind it.
It was a glowing,
oval-shaped object.
NARRATOR: The object was also
witnessed and photographed
by numerous Hangzhou residents.
When the UFO was seen,
all hell broke loose.
Flights were diverted.
The military was
contacted to see
if they were test flying
anything in the area,
which they weren't.
This is the third such
incident in five years in China
where the presence of a UFO
has either shut down an airport
or caused havoc and amazement
amongst the populace.
And it's clearly something that
the Chinese government want
to shut down and play down.
It could also be due to
the fact that the Chinese
have realized they're not in
control of their airspace.
Somebody else is.
[speaking mandarin]
INTERPRETER: The Xiaoshan
event is only one
of the events of this kind.
The same thing happened
in Guizhou province.
At that time, the pilots were
instructed to avoid the UFO,
ground their aircrafts,
and returned to the air
after the event,
which can provide
evidence of the existence
of the UFO phenomenon.
NARRATOR: While many
in the United States
view the UFO phenomena
as distinctly American,
recent surveys have
shown that roughly half
of the 1.4 billion
Chinese people
believe in UFOs and
extraterrestrial life.
And ancient astronaut
theorists suggest
that, despite the Chinese
government's dismissal
of recent UFO events,
it now appears
they, too, are
taking an interest
in otherworldly phenomena.
It's incredibly
popular in China
to be a member of
a UFO community
that's trying to make contact
with extraterrestrial beings.
The Chinese government is
closely monitoring this,
and in fact, they're financing
some of these research groups.
So one wonders-- is
the Chinese government
starting to view our contact
with extraterrestrial beings
as something simply
too strong to deny?
NARRATOR: Could recent events be
forcing the Chinese government
to take a greater
interest in examining
possible extraterrestrial
encounters?
Encounters that they have
secretly known about for years?
Ancient astronaut
theorists say yes,
and suggest that China's effort
to manufacture the world's
largest radio telescope
is an explicit mission
towards the search
for alien life.